[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui connaît l'euro nous a rejoints vers
ce qu'est ce que vous regardez à 19h
vous à la télé rien je mange à cette
heure ci d'accord je suis couché vous
êtes dans l'ambiance un bon s'éclate à
gré à la norme et non seulement le sport
qui ne fait pas chier après j'aime
toucher qu'est ce tu m'emmerdes mais lui
c'est une barre c'était la barre de
patin de philippe candeloro je ratais de
ma mère un frère un sneakers il
s'achetait pas maintenant frère et masi
et des petits écoliers et des
célébrations des titres positifs ritz et
des after he zhi wen devrait arthur ou
baba où cyril hanouna
si tu dit arthur je te défonce la job à
la fin je vais dire arthur tient mot car
sur le mans la bête vous avez raison
mais les deux ils sont si colin claude
egéa perdu sa virginité à 11 ans je
finis ah ouais c'est vrai et c'est un
des records est loin ce pas loin onze
ans et demi wes américain
j'étais sur ses genoux ou toi fêter avec
lui on se connaît depuis longtemps vous
ans et 4 mois c'est vrai on en a parlé
et m'a battu
j'avais pas encore là a lu la notice
d'utilisation en fait de la bistouquette
fois oui merci mais on va peut-être pas
trop valérie benaïm ou enora malagré les
deux en même temps c'est bien portée
pourrait faire un pareil alors attention
là
[Applaudissements]
sur france télévisions philippe ou pas
toujours voit la semaine prochaine je
pars avec nelson au championnat du monde
mais ça va on s'entend bien il vient
nous voir la semaine prochaine je crois
voulais lui dire un petit truc ben
nelson ne raconte pas trop de conneries
parce que on doit faire de l'audimat
quand même un chien vous avez pas un
truc sur nelson monfort qu'on sait pas
qu'on pourra lui sortir la semaine
prochaine
vous savez pas vous savez tout sur
nelson mais ya pas une petite anecdote
je sais pas il connaît bien des blagues
de cul dray demande et les kilos raconte
une tulipe à fond de vous vous avez un
petit truc vous êtes hyper sympathique
mais il ya tout juste un petit truc
c'est que vous êtes proche de vos sous
tout le monde le dit à chaque fois
passez-moi 50 euros j'étais pas là je te
les passes mais tu m'avais touristes
wallons sont les passes mais tu
m'invites voilà [ __ ] je reparte avec
ses bombes rcc bon match à cadeaux
merci
[Musique]